pourquoi je suis ici à là
tu peux le garder
j'ai rencontré film ait pas
mais tu te rends compte tout le temps tu
non pas comme 7 6
quand un ep édifiante
on vient de deux univers tellement
différent mais j'ai jamais ressenti rien
de tel pour personne faire les quêtes
personne n'a jamais fait ça pour moi la
main
parce que
il va
c'est ce à quoi je suis venu vous
rapporter ça ou à tutoyer ça dans votre
voiture n'est pas été capable de lire
ces lettres depuis des années je peux
vous les lire si vous voulez 10 avril
1940 ma chair rose
je me souviendrai de la robe que tu
portais même lorsque j'aurai oublié mon
nom
j'aimerais pouvoir tout dire que ce
bonheur durera toujours tout le monde
n'a pas cette chance
oui
tout n'a pas été si simple
look vous devez arrêter la prochaine
fois vous trouverez probablement à la
mort c'est ça ma vie c'est tout ce que
je connais je ne peux pas rester avec
quelqu'un quand je ne sais jamais si je
le reverrai à chaque fois qu'ils battent
à bord on est moins tu reviendras
je te promets
je ne sais pas quoi faire ça fonctionne
je ne peux plus continuer comme ça
l'amour exige des sacrifices
mais cela vaut la peine